en côte d'ivoire mais la nuit a été
calme à abidjan après la deuxième nuit
de couvre feu le général robert gueï est
en passe de réussir son coup de force
les commandants militaires des
différentes armes d'infanterie
parachutiste marine gendarmerie se sont
ralliés à lui ainsi que le numéro deux
du parti du président bédié qui cet
après midi à quitter abidjan avec sa
famille pour se réfugier à lomé au togo
lé général robert gueï a par ailleurs
refusé tout renforcement du dispositif
militaire français dans son pays
reportage nos correspondants permanents
eric monier et roger motte
l'ambassadeur de france pour regagner sa
résidence ses négociations avec le
nouveau pouvoir entamer il ya 48 heures
ont enfin abouti
henri konan bédié le président déchu
réfugié dans ce camp des forces
françaises basées en côte d'ivoire vient
de quitter le pays avec sa famille
épilogue d'une prise de pouvoir en
douceur des militaires ivoiriens dès ce
matin abidjan donnait une image de
dimanche à peu près normal la
circulation avait repris des bus si
lionel avis les badauds se pressaient
devant les magasins pillés trente six
heures plus tôt des pillages
spectaculaires mais limité à quelques
rues commerçantes de la capitale
économique ivoirienne
ici ce qu'il reste d'une boutique
d'électroménager appartenant pas un
france
c'est une catastrophe j'sais pas comment
faire franchement c'est dur c'est dur
pour faire baisser la vie il va falloir
faire le nécessaire pour recommencer
dans la rue la foule compatit et
l'argument nous déplora nous le
regrettons ce qui s'est passé wayne
simmonds et vous pensez que ça y est
c'est fini mais non c'est fini on
mettait la situation c'est fini qui
viennent se mettre au gouvernement
s'était déjà responsable un nouveau
gouvernement que le général ken le
nouveau chef de l'état annonce pour
bientôt un général ancien chef d'état
major et hamidou froid ni dont le
charisme dépasse largement le cadre de
l'armée et qui veut aller vite
dès hier ralliement télévisées les plus
hautes personnalités de l'ère bédié
cet après midi remise en route de
l'administration qui devrait fonctionner
normalement demain et pour faire bonne
figure
la population a pu se rendre aujourd'hui
au camp militaire d'akouédo pour
réclamer la restitution de ces véhicules
empruntent et quelques jours par les
militaires pour cause de coup d'état
il aura fallu moins de 48 heures pour
qu'un mouvement d'humeur de jeunes
soldats ne tourne en prise de pouvoir en
surfant sur une vague de mécontentement
général que ni l'ancien président ni son
allié la france l'avait prise au sérieux